vous avez été près de 500 milles sur
figaro live à suivre en direct le
premier lancement de space x vers les
essais samedi 30 mai à 21h22 merci à
vous merci aux commentateurs de la
société astronomique de france qui
étaient avec nous alors on se retrouve
le lendemain de ce décollage historique
pour faire un point sur le voyage des
deux astronautes qui ont réussi leur
amarrage à l'iss est à l'heure où nous
postons cette vidéo nous allons voir
comment s'est passée leur voyage avec
les premières images des astronautes bob
et 12 dans l'espace à bord de la capsule
dragon jusqu'à l'amarrage c'est-à-dire
l'accrochage de la capsule à la station
spatiale internationale
mais avant je dois vous montrer la
réaction d'un homme
c'était hier soir au décollage est cet
homme
ces lots de masques le patron de space x
est justement sans plus attendre voyons
comment s'est déroulé le voyage des deux
astronautes qui a duré 19 heures un
voyage durant lequel ils ont effectué
divers tests je rappelle que c'est la
première fois que space x envoie des
humains verdier cesse et ils ont aussi
un peu fait le show
[Musique]
et enfin nous y voilà
le 31 mai à 16 heures 16 heures
françaises nous sommes à 400 km de la
surface de la terre les ss tourne autour
de la terre à la vitesse de 27 mille
kilomètres heure et la capsule la samare
et
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une capsule russe soyouz
kissama rallye es16 comme c'était le cas
depuis 2011 on se souvient par exemple
du voyage du français thomas pesquet en
2016 sur soyouz vous faisiez peut-être
partie des 3 millions de personnes qui
avaient suivi sa à l'époque sur figaro
live mais cette fois ci c'est bien la
capsule américaine de space x
voilà l'équipage de crewe dragonne a
rejoint les trois occupants qui étaient
déjà dans la station spatiale
internationale un américain chris
cassidy et 2 russe anatoli ivanichine et
ivan wagner
on ne sait pas encore exactement combien
de temps ils vont rester plusieurs
semaines le patron de la nasa a parlé
d'un possible retour au début du mois
d'août
[Musique]
en tout cas abonnez vous pour ne rien
rater puisque évidemment on suivra ça en
direct sur figaro live
[Musique]